FAILURE TO ACT NOW WOULD BE THE
DEATH KNELL OF THE UNITED
NATIONS ITSELF.
BRET?
>> Bret: BENJAMIN, THANK YOU.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
CONSIDERING A PERSPECTIVE OFFER
FROM REPUBLICAN DONOR ADELSON TO
PAY FOR THE SOON TO BE RELOCATED
EMBASSY IN JERUSALEM.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
OR POLITICALLY WISE.
AND HOW FAST IT WILL HAPPEN.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON IS HERE
TONIGHT WITH THAT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
AND STATE DEPARTMENT ATTORNEYS
ARE LOOKING INTO IT, WHETHER AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN CAN LEGALLY
HELP PAY FOR A UNITED STATES
EMBASSY.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
TELLS FOX NEWS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS RECEIVED NO
OFFICIAL OFFER FROM SHELDON
ADELSON AND NO FORMAL
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE DONATION
THOUGH THE OFFICIALS REFUSE TO
RULE OUT INFORMAL OR UNOFFICIAL
TALKS OR OFFERS BETWEEN THE TWO.
THEY CLAIM THE DONATION FROM A
PROFOUNDLY PRO ISRAEL REPUBLICAN
DONOR WOULD ALLOW OTHER
POLITICALLY ACTIVE GROUPS TO
FOLLOW AND INJECT MORE POLITICS
INTO AN ALREADY SENSITIVE
SITUATION.
THIS AS STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS SAY SECRETARY
TILLERSON HAS JUST APPROVED A
SECURITY PLAN TO OPEN THE U.S.
EMBASSY IN AN EXISTING FACILITY
IN JERUSALEM BY MAY.
IN TIME FOR THE 70TH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE STATE OF ISRAEL, WELL
AHEAD OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
2019 TARGET, AND FULFILLING A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
>> RIGHT THING TO DO.
WE HAVE TO DO IT.
BUT EVERY OTHER PRESIDENT REALLY
LIED BECAUSE THEY CAMPAIGNED ON
IT.
THAT WAS ALWAYS A BIG PART OF
THE CAMPAIGN.
THEN THEY GOT INTO OFFICE.
THEY NEVER DID IT.
>> THE OFFICIAL STRESSES THE NEW
U.S. EMBASSY WILL ONLY HAVE A
FOOTPRINT IN JERUSALEM BY MAY.
WITH THE TARGET STILL OF OPENING
A LARGER PRESENCE THERE BY THE
END OF 2019.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS
INITIALLY, THE INTERIM EMBASSY
WILL HAVE AN OFFICE FOR THE
AMBASSADOR AND A SMALL STAFF.
OFFICIALS SAY SEPARATELY, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING FOR
A SITE TO BUILD A PERMANENT U.S.